عبرت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقي واشنطن
من اقتحام
لبحات الاقصى الذي وصفته بالاستفزازي ومما
صاحبه من خطاب تحريضي وفق ما قالت واضافت
في بيان انه لا يجوز استخدام المواقع
المقدسه لغرض سياسيه وان الولايات المتحده
تدعو جميع الاطراف في الاحترام قدسيه تلك
المواقع كما الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
انزعاجها الشديد من السماح للحكومه هي
الاسرائيليه للاسرائيليين بالاقامه بشكل
دائم في مستوطنه حومش الواقعه الشماليه
الضفه الغربيه مشيره الى ان القانون
الاسرائيلي نفسه ينص على ان المستوطنه
وقيمت بشكل غير قانوني على اراضي فلسطينيه
خاصه واعتبر البيان ان المضي قدما في بناء
المستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه يعتبر عقبه
امام تحقيق حل الدولتين